hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to happy wheels now I
got a save is the first thing I've
recorded in my new apartment is not
final I have no soundproofing on the
wall or echo reduction and I have no
idea what the noise tolerance of my
neighbors is gonna be like so let's find
out with some good old-fashioned
screaming also white walls weird I know
entered well right then I didn't even
know what I was supposed to do
[Music]
oh that looks somehow very wrong I think
I'm enjoying it okay nope nevermind oh
[Applause]
it's the perfect balance of what you
need and what you don't need Oh suck it
jack I know that sounded like suck and
Jack but it meant suck it Jack not
sucking Jack don't do that that's bad
advice
good advice slow why slow whoa there we
go okay well my kid has been mangled so
this house like one fan is banging
[Music]
I could never annoyed me why do I need
to kill him oh sorry am I going on an
adventure
nope apparently okay there I go not
where I wanted to but I mean you love me
let me show my affection for you there
you go come on
who made this why don't people make this
for me
actually there's been a lot of people
[Music]
thing I've ever seen I'm so jealous
good job Cass be 1405 seriously that's
awesome well then who's going poorly ok
bye son apparently oh oh I missed one
well I think that's actually the least
of my concerns at the moment
jacksepticeye the sparrow
[Music]
whoa no okay I'm just trying to hit Wade
not Tim okay mr. Wade Wade just gave up
all right Wade cut his own balls off
that's good no oh my god wait for the
music then dance then
[Laughter]
Oh
[Music]
Thank You Casspi 1405 before that's the
same person that did the jacksepticeye
level you guys making these levels in
especially Casspi 1405 thank you so much
for making these you guys are amazing
and guys if you want to play these for
yourself just look up markiplier in
happy wheels and play them sorted by
newest or whatever and please rate up
your favourite ones or comment down
below with your favorite games I really
want the community to know about these
games and want them to play it they are
amazing thank you anyway I guess I'm all
out of time so I'm actually doing an
outro for happy wheels which I've never
done before but I'll be back up and run
new apartment soundproofing and this has
been happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you want to see more happy
wheels right now check the description
or click the annotation for the full
happy wheels playlist and if you want to
see more happy wheels in the future
please click the like button to let me
know thanks again everyone and as always
I will see you in the next video